Nó này nghe người ta mùi nắm hành hủ chăm hành lắm,
công an tỉnh còn ninh thông tin bà đầu vụ việc có giống hiệu dưới người.
Cứ tại sản tại phượng bình phê tỉnh còn nỉnh.
Thưa đó, khoảng chiến dừa cùng ngay,
công an phượng bình phê nhận được tinh báo về việc
và hiện bà để tế tế tế,
sinh năm 1945,
chú tại khu chăm mối bê,
phượng bình phê tỉnh còn ninh từ vong trưa gió mình nhìn tại nhà dương.
Sau khi tí bệnh tỉnh báo,
lãng gạo công an tỉnh đã chỉ đạo,
người động các lực lượng hình chương,
đến hình đưa tra, sống mình làm só hủ vụ.
Đông chỉ thử ta cù cuốc tham,
phó ra m đốc,
tù trường các quang kể rất đưa tra công an tỉnh đã chức tiếp có mặt tại hiện chương.
Chỉ đạo các lực lượng chức năng tập trung đưa tra làm só hủ an.
Khi có đưa tra bà đầu rất định,
bà tế xí xong mục mình,
bán hàng tập quá tại nhà dương.
Sau không thể và không linh lạc được vui bà tế từ chương quá,
đông thơi phát hiện nhà bà tế có giống hộ bất thường.
Nó dân đã li là quý con gái bà tế là chi mơ.
Xin năm 2020, chú tại khu biến quà phù mọc hế,
tình quang linh, đến phát cửa và nhà kìm ra.
Tại đây, phát hiện bà tế đã thử vong trong tư thế năm vừa giới định nhà,
trên tay bị trỏi,
tại hiện chương phát hiện có giấu với kể phát cửa tế các phòng,
một con lợt đất bị đế phớt, không còn tìm bị trông.
Màng các bị phát nghiệp vụ,
để khoảng 18 giờ, mề lắm phút cùng ngày,
các quan cung an đã bà giữ nghi phạm buổi ngọt đức,
Xin năm 2020,
thương chú tại phương át tự, tình quang,
nơi ở hiện nay, khu trẻ mối bệ phòng bi khy tình quang linh.
Đối trên khai thác, đối tượng đặc hai nhận tổn bộ hành vi phạm tổn.
Hịt, các quan cạnh rất đều trà công an tình quang linh đang tập trung chỉ đạo đều trà,
sử lý trên địa các đối tượng có linh quán,
nếu có theo quy định của phát lợt.